madame monsieur bonsoir rebondissement
dans la sphère des fausses factures de
la région parisienne robert pandraud
l'ancien ministre de la sécurité et
proche de jacques chirac vient d'être
mise en examen
coup de théâtre à valenciennes au procès
et au mv à l'ancienne attachée
parlementaire du député jacques mellick
affirme avoir menti aux enquêteurs
à la demande de son patron dans le
journal un tête à tête très attendu
entre valéry giscard d'estaing et
jacques chirac à chamalières
les soupçons de la justice sur
l'existence d'une caisse noire alimentée
par le groupe alcatel
le plan de sauvetage du crédit lyonnais
et puis un quatuor de choix invité de
notre journal annie girardot michel
boujenah claude lelouch et francis lai
pour l'un des événements
cinématographiques de l'année la sortie
mercredi des misérables l'oeuvre de
victor hugo revisité par club le bon
soir en pleine période électorale la
faire des fausses factures de la région
parisienne parisienne connaît donc ce
soir un développement de taille après
michel roussin l'ancien ministre de la
coopération
robert pandraud émises à son tour en
examen l'ancien ministre de la sécurité
est considéré comme un proche de jacques
chirac
thierry kurt et 1986 robert pandraud
passe de l'ombre à la lumière
celui qui a fait toute sa carrière dans
la police il en fut le directeur général
devient ministre de la sécurité
travaillant avec charles pasqua ministre
de l'intérieur
derrière cette pipe cette démarche
lourde se cache un fidèle de jacques
chirac il est resté ce soir robert
pandraud est mise en examen pour recel
d'abus de biens sociaux
la justice lui reproche un fait l'un de
ses collaborateurs au conseil régional
ile de france est en fait le salarié
d'une société ayant décroché de nombreux
marchés du conseil régional justement
est ce collaborateur c'est rémy alvac ce
policier syndicaliste et meneur des
grèves de 84 il avait été exclu de la
police en 86
robert pandraud le prend sous son aile
ils ne se quitteront plus cette mise en
examen ce soir est une étape
supplémentaire pour eric halphen
le juge de créteil chargé de l'enquète
sur les fausses factures des hlm se
concentre désormais sur les volets ville
paris et ile de france il avait déjà mis
en examen un autre ministre en exercice
celui ci michel roussin il se passe
toujours quelque chose au procès om
valenciennes le coup de théâtre du jour
est venue de l'ancienne attachée
parlementaire de jacques mellick le
député socialiste de béthune elle
affirme avoir menti au moment de
l'instruction sur l'ordre de son patron
et ce pour disculper bernard tapie
dominique verdeilhan et benoît gadret à
valenciennes le calme alternent avec les
moments de folie en fin de matinée
corinne hadj skis ex attachée
parlementaire de jacques mellick quitte
le palais de justice
en un éclair est plutôt bien encadré
quelques minutes plus tôt elle vient de
porter une double accusation contre son
ancien patron le 17 juin 93
pl je n'étais pas avec jacques mellick
dans le bureau de bernard tapie
c'est jacques mellick qui m'a demandé de
mentir à ce moment là bernard tapie
accuse le coup plus tard en présence de
jacques mellick elle persiste hier il
est venu me voir pour me demander de
maintenir mon mensonge de plus il a même
fait allusion à mon mari qui est encore
salarié à béthune ce sont les bars à
témoin c'était ma collaboratrice avait
souhaité me rencontrer collaborateurs
deuxième coup dur pour bernard tapie qui
soudain prend ses distances avec son
élite
j'attends qu'ils m'expliquent pourquoi
au moment où ou ce matin je lui je lui
donne l'ouverture importante pour qui
pour qu'ils se sortent d'un sale pas
parce que de toute évidence et une
contradiction forte avec son assistante
alors que je vous rappel c'est son
secrétariat qui nous indique qu'il est
chez moi le 17 si on a les personnes
très vite âge
c'est pas sur les paniers bernard tapie
s'est exécuté et jacques mellick est
reparti vers béthune la ville dont il
est le maire où là encore la justice
l'attend alors jacques mellick se
trouvait-il dans le bureau de bernard
tapie ce 17 juin 1993 à cette question
jacques mellick a toujours répondu oui
mais son emploi du temps ce jour là ne
plaide pas en sa faveur un rappel de cet
épisode controversé avec philippe
boisserie jusqu'à aujourd'hui jacques
mellick était surtout célèbre pour le
pari béthune le plus rapide de
l'histoire
1h10 alors qu'il faut en voulant à 152
moyenne au moins une heure quarante
tout cela pour rendre crédible sa
présence dans le bureau de bernard tapie
entre 14h30 et 14h45 le 17 juin 93
le jour où boro primorac aurait été
approché par le président de l'om pour
qu'il modifie son témoignage pour
renforcer la libye son attaché
parlementaire
confirmé ou nié at-il bien mais voilà
une gazette de béthune annoncé la
présence de jacques mellick dans sa
ville à 14 heures sur les photos les
montrent de certains indiqué 14h35 ou
14h50
et puis le chauffeur du député se
trouvait prendre de l'essence à 13h30 à
béthune et puis une béthunoise révélé
avoir rencontré madame trajet ce qui est
monsieur mellick à 14 heures et puis
rien n'allait plus je dis oui
machination politique et je pèse mes
mots
pendant quelques jours jacques mellick
avait refusé de répondre à la
convocation du juge défi physique y
était allé pour lui dire qu'il ne lui
dirai rien je vais demander aux
magistrats
ma mise en examen
ce jour là jacques mellick savait qu'il
ne craignait rien aujourd'hui les choses
ont bien changé dominique verdeilhan est
indirecte de valenciennes dominique vous
suivez ce procès depuis le début de la
semaine mais l'on peut dire ce soir que
la semaine finie beaucoup plus mal pour
bernard tapie qu'elle n'a
commencer oui on peut parler etienne
d'un effet boomerang pour bernard tapie
d'ailleurs bernard tapie le reconnaît
lui-même ce soir la déposition de son ex
collègue du gouvernement est
catastrophique dramatique pour moi dit
il pour lui et pour ce qu'on représente
c'est vrai qu'il restera de cette folle
journée une désagréable impression celle
d'avoir juin députés à un maire et un
ancien ministre
aussi méprisant vis-à-vis de
l'institution judiciaire alors sur le
dossier
c'est simple et accablant aussi pour
bernard tapie car vous le comprenez bien
il ne peut pas y avoir eu autant de
dépositions à géométrie variable autant
de faux témoignages autant de
subornation de témoin si au départ il
n'y a pas eu corruption
autrement dit la semaine s'achève plutôt
bien pour jean pierre bernès ça n'est
donc pas finie pour tapie mais ça n'est
pas fini non plus pour jacques mellick
non et je peux vous dire que les choses
vont très vite puisque ce soir le
parquet de béthune qui est
territorialement compétent a ouvert une
enquête en flagrance pour subornation de
témoin et dans ce cas précis je vous
précise que jacques mellick n'est pas
protégé par son immunité parlementaire
alors le srpj de lille est d'ores et
déjà saisi ce qui veut dire que jacques
mellick pourraient être entendues dans
les heures qui viennent et s'il le faut
placer en garde à vue et si les faits le
justifie et bien jacques mellick dans
les jours prochains pourrait être
appelée à comparaître devant un tribunal
correctionnel
merci bien dominique verdeilhan le juge
d'instruction renaud van ruymbeke at il
découvert une caisse noire au sein du
groupe alcatel il aurait mis la main en
belgique sur un compte alimenté par
l'entreprise de pierre sueur qui
affirmer ici même mercredi soir n'avoir
jamais verser d'argent à des partis
politiques michèle fines et pascal
c'est dans ce petit immeuble de
bruxelles sur un compte ouvert à la
banque du minime le blé que le
conseiller renaud van ruymbeke a
retrouvé la trace de ce qui pourrait
être la caisse noire d'alcatel ce
comptes alimentés par des virements
d'alcatel séité a vu transiter en cinq
ans de 87 à 91 des dizaines
millions de francs le compte était
ouvert au nom d'un certain marc barbe
aujourd'hui renaud van ruymbeke
qu'aimerait bien d'interroger ce
mystérieux personnage de nationalité
franco britannique mais il serait
douteux on voyage en chine chez alcatel
séité marque barde n'est pas un inconnu
on confirme qu'il faisait partie de la
centaine d'intermédiaires utilisé pour
négocier les contrats à l'exportation en
rémunération de ses services marc barbe
percevait dit on des commissions que
faisait-il ensuite de cet argent ce
n'est pas notre problème
répondons chez alcatel est ce que vous
pouvez ce soir nous affirmer qu'il
qu'alcatel alstom n'a jamais verser
d'argent aux partis politiques
les seuls la réponse est claire c'est
non
nous allons nous nous battons contre des
fantasmes cette sphère fantasme
peut-être pas en mars/avril 88 le compte
alimenté par alcatel en belgique verse 5
millions de francs sur un autre compte
celui ci est ouvert au luxembourg au nom
d'alain cellier un homme que le
conseiller vendre une bête connaît bien
le magistrat soupçonnent cet ami de
gérard longuet de gérer la caisse noire
du parti républicain il sait qu'en avril
88 au moment du virement de 5 millions
de francs alain sellier a rencontré
pierre suhard le pdg d'alcatel alsthom
de plus c'est la troisième fois que le
conseiller vendre une bête retrouve sur
les comptes d'alain saignée des
virements d'alcatel lierre de
conseillers rennais a transmis à son
collègue d'evry jean marie d'huy les
fruits de son enquête
on connaît depuis quelques heures les
détails du plan de sauvetage du crédit
lyonnais la banque a perdu
officiellement 50 milliards de francs et
le ministre de l'économie répète
aujourd'hui que le contribuable n'aura
pas à supporter l'effort financier
nécessaire les détails avec pascal
golomer
la mise en scène avec les soigneusement
préparée avec deux acteurs de premier
plan le patron du crédit lyonnais jean
peyrelevade bien sûr le ministre de
l'économie
à leur côté le gouverneur de la banque
de france jean claude trichet et le
directeur du trésor
la question du jour comment sauver une
banque avec une réplique déjà bien rodée
avec le plan de redressement que nous
mettons en place l'état et donc le
contribuable n'aura pas à accroître son
effort financier et pour cela il faut un
scénario plutôt complexe le crédit
lyonnais va se débarrasser en fait de
130 milliards de francs d'actifs logés
dans une nouvelle filiale cdr consortium
de réalisation cela correspond à toutes
les participations dans l'immobilier le
cinéma l'industrie
et puis la plupart des filiales
financières le but c'est de vendre ses
actifs au plus vite l etat qui se
portent garants d'ensemble prévoit tout
de même 50 milliards de francs de pertes
car tout ne se vendra pas bien alors en
contrepartie le crédit lyonnais
reversera pendant 20 ans au moins un
tiers de ses bénéfices à l'état le
crédit lyonnais qui devra en plus faire
une sérieuse cure d'amaigrissement
abandonner certaines activités et se
recentrer sur la france les efforts
qu'on nous demande c'est en fait des
efforts tout à fait naturel c'est de
revenir sur notre métier de base sur
notre métier bancaire de redevenir des
banquiers de refaire notre métier avec
professionnalisme d'être prudents en
matière de risques de donner une bonne
qualité de service au client et à partir
de là comme tous les banquiers de gagner
de l'argent de développer notre
rentabilité des restructurations qui
aboutiront l'an prochain à au moins 1500
suppressions d'emplois supplémentaires
la direction le reconnaît ce soir quant
à la privatisation
elle reste malgré tout à l'ordre du jour
nous devons un rendez-vous au crédit
lyonnais nous lui disons dans cinq ans
si vous travaillez bien et bien vous
serez en situation d'être privatisée de
voler de vos propres ailes et d'euros et
de rembourser l'intégralité de la faire
passer tout le monde veut donc thomas
pages restent impliqués dans les faits
ce jeu de meccano financier
oui dans ce dossier edouard balladur
parlé au début de la semaine
d'éventuelles poursuites judiciaires et
bien le parquet de paris vient d'ouvrir
quatre information judiciaire contre x
relatives à des opérations menées dans
le domaine commercial et immobilier par
la banque altus qui est une filiale du
crédit lyonnais
les syndicats de leur côté refusent de
payer par des suppressions d'effectifs
les erreurs commises ces dernières
années en revanche pas grande inquiétude
chez les clients de la banque réactions
recueillies par jean yves perrin et jan
cornet visiblement les déboires du
crédit lyonnais ne touche guère ses
clients plan de sauvetage ou non on
reste serein moi je lui fais confiance
j'espère que la banque retombera sur ses
pieds c'était une banque quand même
suffisamment costaud pour supporter des
actions à mon avis beaucoup plus inquiet
les salariés de la banque déjà bousculée
par un plan social commencé en mars 94
qui prévoit 3800 départ sur trois ans il
ya une demande de la part de l'état
d'augmenter la productivité de 15% donc
nécessairement au niveau français le
plan social était à naucelle 3800
suppressions de postes risquent d'être
pratiquement doublé si on fait un calcul
le président du crédit lyonnais lui
parle de 1500 suppressions d'emplois
supplémentaires
mais quel que soit le chiffre les
salariés savent qu'ils paieront pour les
erreurs de gestion de leurs dirigeants
la campagne électorale maintenant est
incontestablement l'une des images
fortes du jour la rencontre dans le
puy-de-dôme à chamalières entre valéry
giscard d'estaing et jacques chirac un
tête à tête qui était très attendu sur
place j'ai vite imbert et jacques gérard
la venue de jacques chirac au conseil
régional d'auvergne dans les murs de
valéry giscard d'estaing
voilà bien un véritable événement un
descriptif de couilles autour du
candidat gaulliste qui va mettre
plusieurs minutes pour effectuer des bus
mètres qui le séparent de la faune soeur
du bâtiment arrivait enfin au quatrième
étage c'est la fosse aux ventes
attendues la poignée de main certes un
peu rapide mais on les a si souvent
premiers rivaux qu'on ne résiste pas à
les revoir conflit l'ancien président et
son ancien premier ministre ont passé
une heure en tête à tête à l'abri des
regards les deux hommes ont sans doute
confirmer les amabilités il s'adresse
depuis quelques jours jacques chirac
rappelant l'expérience précieuse de
valéry giscard d'estaing vge saluant le
discours européen du maire de paris
bref l'entente cordiale affichée même si
giscard l'a bien dit il n'apportera
aucun soutien public avant le premier
lourd et recevra dans les mêmes
conditions edouard balladur ce 7 avril
il n'empêche la rencontre de chamalières
aura beaucoup d'importance pour jacques
chirac
il y reçoit une sorte de label du
gardien qui peaufine encore un peu plus
son image de rassembleur
les sondages se succèdent et se
ressemblent jacques chirac obtiendrait
29 5% des voix au premier tour sondage
csa pour le parisien demain 21 % pour
lionel jospin et 17 5 % seulement pour
edouard balladur le premier ministre
était dans l'yonne aujourd'hui
officiellement c'est le chef du
gouvernement qui se déplacer mais
campagne oblige le candidat a très vite
pris le dessus
jean baptiste près d'albi et gérard
dernier pour le coup de main ce serait
plutôt celui d'un premier ministre
d'ailleurs dans l'yonne aujourd'hui la
visite était officielle avec son lot
d'inauguration et de mesures annoncées
dans d'autres situations
cela ressemblait plutôt aux gets obligé
d'une campagne électorale
entre les deux c'était devenu carrément
politique surtout parce que jean pierre
soisson un des hôtes du premier ministre
avait décidé de mettre les pieds dans le
plat par east il ne choisira que demain
mais il y est allé de son commentaire
sur le défi qui attend edouard balladur
dialogue sur fond historique depuis la
réélection du général de gaulle en 1965
le véritable détenteur de l'exécutif
président la république au premier
ministre dans une période de
cohabitation n'a jamais pu gagner une
élection présidentielle la période
actuelle est une période plus difficile
en tout cas pour celui qui vous parle
que celle qu'elle était il ya un mois
que ceux qui seraient tentés de s'en
préoccuper se rassure elle peut
parfaitement redevenir dans un mois ce
qu'elle était il ya un mois et vous
pouvez être assurés que je m'y
emploierai que je m'y emploie
et pour les travaux pratiques edouard
balladur s'y est employé sur le champ
avec un geste au choix de premier
ministre ou de candidats de son côté
lionel jospin disait hier qu'il ne se
déplacerait pas pour voter s'ils
n'étaient pas présents au second tour il
a fait un peu machine arrière
aujourd'hui dans le pas de calais
la question était mal posée at il dit
est de toute façon je serai présent au
deuxième tour avec le nen jospin roland
sicard et marie pierre cassignard une
campagne électorale c'est comme le tour
de france il y a des étapes obligées et
des étapes qui porte chance
et pour un candidat socialiste l'étape
du pays minier au lieu de lutte
syndicale et de reconversion
industrielle est une grande classique
alors il ya une chose pour la visite
lionel jospin écoute lionel jospin
répond et lionel jospin parfois
plaisante
c'était un patron pas trop dur
bref une campagne c'est comme ça les
candidats s'y plient c'est un exercice
difficile qui intéresse même les
psychanalystes on s'aperçoit qu'à
travers ce parcours du combattant que
chaque candidat doit faire pour
témoigner qu'il est un homme comme les
autres
on voit chacun d'une certaine façon
quand même trouver la distance qui est
la sienne
mais cette distance lionel jospin essai
de la réduire le candidat va multiplier
les visites et les meetings est avec un
message simple il faut mobiliser
lionel jospin qui durcit le ton c'est
que sa campagne qui avait plutôt bien
commencé semble marquer le pas alors le
candidat du ps veut contre-attaquer et
accélérer bref se faire entendre
la progression du candidat socialiste
dans les sondages marquent un peu le pas
c'est sur le terrain qu'il a donc décidé
on vient de le voir de partir à la
conquête de nouveaux électeurs
aidé en cela par les militants du ps qui
préparent chacun de ses déplacements en
province et parfois dans des conditions
difficiles guilaine chenu et michel jane
latos il arrive seule minute accueillir
le candidat
rien de tel pour lancer la campagne dans
un département même si la visite
n'excédera pas cinq heures c'est tout
l'appareil du parti qui s'est mobilisé
depuis une semaine de réunions en
préparation tout est réglé comme un
ballet de l'entrée en scène de chez lui
le sait les genres de la rue des arts
jusqu'à l'entracte il faut faire avec
les moyens du bord il y a les
photocopieuses qui tourne pour édicter
des milliers de tracts et les affiches
de paris attendue depuis longtemps et
qu'il faut coller je pense que nos
militants ont balisé un peu toulouse
cette nuit oui puisque nous avons reçu
les affiches qui hier encore un peu
juste pour pour l'aca venu aujourd'hui
faire vite et avec peu de moyens c'est
la devise de cette campagne en une
semaine il a fallu trouver un local et
faire appel à la générosité des
socialistes pour payer le loyer
tous les jours des petits chats
et toute cette organisation repose
souvent sur les bonnes volontés
direction l'aéroport pour cette
militante chercher les journalistes
venus de paris et pour cela il a fallu
prendre une journée de congé c'est à la
fois un rail
intéressant et valorisant est peu
présent il y avait pas d inconvénient
grandeur et solitude du militant à
l'arrivée le candidat passe au pas de
charge car avant tout il faut respecter
le programme alors dit il est là dans la
foule
soulagement la visite peut commencer et
pour les militants
tous les espoirs sont permis à
l'étranger maintenant après 25 ans de
drames et de violence la traditionnelle
saint patrick le patron de l'irlande a
été célébrée aujourd'hui sous le signe
de la paix une immense fête populaire
dont la politique n'est toutefois pas
rester absentes à dublin aujourd'hui
bernard lebrun la petite fille et
irlandaises
les drapeaux aussi le bâtiment du
blinois mais la musique est américaine
comme ce char qui célèbre le million
d'immigrants partis là bas il ya 150 ans
lors de la terrible famine
aujourd'hui pour la première
saint-patrick de la paix ils sont plus
de cent mille américains avoir
retraversé l'atlantique et pour la fête
comme en politique l'influencent des
états unis se fait terriblement sentir
parfois trop au goût des irlandais
restés au pays ont créé là c'est tout le
paradoxe de ce petit pays 3 millions six
cent mille habitants 5 millions avec
l'ulster qui possède une diaspora de 70
millions de personnes dont plus de la
moitié vit aux états unis et 40 millions
d'électeurs d'origine irlandaise pour un
bill clinton en difficulté
ce n'est pas négligeable tout son
interventionnisme dans les négociations
du pays l'imposé unis dans cette bande
intérêts favorable mais jusqu'ici nous
n'avons pas demandé leur aide très
calmement parce que ces problèmes
doivent être réglés entre nous et entre
nous et la grande bretagne
en attendant les devises rentrer la
bière coule à flots les irlandais
commémore cette première sympathiques
boulangers dans l'allégresse tout le
monde a le droit de dire pour la grande
parade face à face tic à dublin y
compris la sent pas des employés des
prisons irlandaise et il est vrai que
ces prisons aujourd'hui l'hiver au
festivent mans tous les prisonniers
politiques tant catholiques protestants
vaste opération anti mafia en sicile 500
policiers réquisitionnés pour une grande
rafle baptisé vendredi noir qui a permis
d'arrêter 16 mafieux présumé accusé
notamment de l'assassinât de domenico
keita le cousin du plus célèbre des
repenti de la mafia la vie de ceux qui
ont décidé de dénoncer les trafics en
tous genres est menacée en permanence en
italie ils sont obligés de se cacher
notre correspondant à rome alain de
chalvron a rencontré l'un de ces
repentis regarder cet homme qui
téléphonent en marchant lentement dans
les rues de rome
vous ne verrez jamais son visage c'est
un homme menacé petit mafieux repenti il
est un des principaux accusateurs de
nidau santapaola le sanguinaire patron
de la mafia à catane deuxième ville de
sicile un des principaux chefs de cosa
nostra jusqu'à son arrestation en mai 93
je suis témoin de l'accusation contre le
chef de la mafia en sicile avant tout à
cause de l'assassinât de mon frère
rosano à la suite d'un différend
concernant la répartition de l'argent du
racket
depuis l'assassinât en sicile de deux
familiers de repentis pier giorgio
pantano apple je sais qu'il y a déjà eu
une première tentative contre ma
personne dans deux repentis du clan sans
doute à paola ont dit que j'étais
condamné à mort mais je suis serein
si la mafia a juré de mme exterminer moi
et ma famille il n'y a qu'une question
quand pantano est un des 968 repenti
officiel recensés en italie et un dé 413
qui bénéficient du programme spécial de
protection de la part de l'état
maintenant je vis dans une localité
secrète j'ai changé mon nom mon prénom
je suis payée par l'état je suis libre
même si je suis sous la protection du
service central opérationnel qui a la
tutelle et des collaborateurs de justice
mais malgré tout une personne comme moi
vit seul et se sent parfois dépressive
cacher aujourd'hui derrière ses lunettes
noires il sous son bonnet pantano c'est
trop bien qu'on le retrouvera un jour il
espère seulement que sa vente d'état la
condamnation de santa paula aura eu le
temps de s'accomplir dans le sud du
liban maintenant de nouveaux incidents
aujourd'hui entre des vedettes de la
marine israélienne et des pêcheurs
libanais qui ne peuvent s'éloigner des
côtes
pourtant il y a dix sept ans une
résolution des nations unies demandait
le retrait des troupes israéliennes du
sud-liban une résolution qui est resté
lettre morte attire donc au sud liban le
reportage d'isabelle bechler et
dominique merlet les 550 pêcheurs du
port de tyr au sud liban ont passé une
semaine militante
à peine sorti d'un mois de blocus imposé
par israël il préparait la journée du
sud
événement national de protestation
contre l'occupation israélienne
pendant un mois empêché de sortir à plus
d'un kilomètre de la côte ils étaient
pris entre le marteau israéliens et
l'enclume libanaise
pas de poisson pas de revenus à chaque
sortie pour poser les filets ou les
remontées il risquer leur vie et jettent
avoir regarder dans quel état ils
mettent nos flotteur ça c'est la méthode
des vedettes israéliennes la pire et
dessus pour qu'ils prennent l'eau
écouler nos filets quand on sort en mer
et tire vers nos bas sans sommation
pourquoi on n'en sait rien simplement on
constate qu'il reprenne le bloc ils
feront donc tous sortis comme un seul
homme ce de tirer ce de saïda 20 km plus
au nord pour protester contre ce blocus
et l'occupation israélienne si jérusalem
a officiellement renoncé au blocus des
ports du sud liban la semaine dernière
c'était sur l'insistance de one
christopher le secrétaire d'état
américain en tournée de négociations de
paix au proche orient
mais cette semaine on revoit les
vedettes israéliennes croiser au large
et intimider les pêcheurs tirent sans
sommation destruction de filet jérusalem
a repris sa pression sur beyrouth
car j'avais récupéré mes fils et quand
les vedettes israéliennes sont venus un
soldat tiré vers moi donc j'ai retroussé
chemin après je les ai vus tailladé mes
filets dès que le liban intensifie ses
checkpoint à la sortie de la zone de
sécurité pour éviter l'importation de
denrées israélienne la guéguerre du
blocus reprend les pêcheurs du sud ne
savent plus sur quel pied danser
retour en france maintenant avec la
bouleversante histoire d'une collégienne
du havre victime d'attouchements sexuels
de la part d'un ami de sa famille
les faits remontent à il ya quelques
mois semble-t-il c'est le directeur de
son école qui a été alertée par une
phrase que l'adolescente avait écrites
dans une rédaction
l'enquète de vincent nguyen et bernard
ronfler pourquoi les petites filles se
font violer c'était il ya un mois dans
une rédaction sur les droits de l'enfant
les mots d'une collégienne de 13 ans à
peine
des mots qui sonnent comme un cri un
appel à l'aide
kassian entendre son professeur
l'enseignante a rapidement alerté le
directeur
le psychologue de l'établissement et
l'inspection académique qui a fait part
de ce problème aux procureurs du à la
fillette et sa petite soeur ont subi de
92 à 94 des attouchements sexuels de la
part d'un ami de la famille les
instituteurs les professeurs ont un rôle
d' alerte qui fait partie de leur
quotidien enfin ils prolongent leur
travail par
un rôle d'assistance sociale au sens
large qui est tout à fait essentiel
c'est lors de réunions anti alcoolique
il ya cinq ans que l'homme accusé d'abus
sexuels a rencontré le père des
fillettes
il les recevait parfois chez lui le
week-end
mercredi il a été mis en examen puis
écroué à la prison du havre
ce qui n'aurait pu se produire sans le
bon réflexe de l'enseignant en même
temps ce réflexe s'inscrit dans la
coopération reconnaît avec l'éducation
nationale l'inspecteur d'académie les
services de police avec la mise en place
de correspondants et de confidences si
je puis dire
le confident citoyens si je puis dire et
donc on constate encore une fois que
l'école c'est le dernier territoire de
la république et c'est peut-être aussi
lancé y en a peut-être le dernier à qui
l'enfant peut avoir confiance quand ils
désespèrent du reste des adultes sur le
nombre toujours trop important de cas
d'enfants victimes d'abus sexuels
beaucoup sont découverts comme cette
fois à l'école mais on en parle encore
peu il subsiste un tabou
qu'il serait temps de briser
2500 cas d'abus sexuels ont été recensés
pour la seule année 94 par l'association
enfance et partage
cette association prend en charge les
enfants et les adolescents pour les
aider à parler du drame qui l'ont vécue
souvent dans un silence coupable
florence biglia et philippe deslandes
enfance et partage bonjour oui et alors
ah bon pourquoi ça t'arrive souvent trop
souvent et c'est pour cela que cet
enfant à oser oser briser la chape de
silence qui est enveloppé son drame
jusqu'à aujourd'hui le numéro vert
d'enfance et partage reçoit chaque année
plus de 7000 appels d'enfants victimes
de négligence de mauvais traitements ou
plus difficile encore à dire d'abus
sexuels ce qui est surtout important
pour pour l'enfant de l'adolescent c'est
de parler de livrer
ce qui lui arrive et nous on peut
recadrer la situation en lui expliquant
qu'il est victime que ce n'est pas
normal qu il y a des lois que c'est un
crime en cas d'inceste ou de viols et
est donc on essaie de lui redonner sa
place de victimes sa place réelle en lui
disant que s'il parle ici l'auteur des
faits va en prison ce n'est pas à cause
de lui mais à cause de ce que l'autre a
fait sur lui souvent l'enfant a peur des
suites judiciaires de sa plainte
l'association le soutien jusqu'à ce
qu'il soit prêt alors seulement elle
signale son cas au procureur de la
république et se constitue
éventuellement partie civile aux assises
s'il s'agit d'abus sexuels en 1994 les
mauvais traitements à enfants étaient en
augmentation
peut-être parce qu'ils sont mieux
répertorier cab ombre sans doute aussi à
cause de la dégradation du tissu social
en cas de besoin téléphoner au 05 05
1 2 3 4 voilà après l'actualité
particulièrement chargé de ce vendredi
je vous propose d'en venir maintenant à
l'un des événements cinématographiques
de l'année je pèse mes mots la sortie
mercredi dans toutes les salles de
france des misérables version claude
lelouch une oeuvre de trois heures et
une distribution très fournie que
lelouch que nous retrouvons dans sa
salle fétiche du club 13 en compagnie
d'annie girardot de michel boujenah et
de francis lai qui a signé la musique
bonsoir et re bonsoir à tous je pense
vous entendez bien maintenant parfait
claude lelouch l'oeuvre de victor hugo a
traversé les époques et je crois que le
nous le nom de thénardier l'aubergiste
de victor hugo évoque pour vous un
souvenir très précis bien c'est le
premier mot effectivement que qui m'a
alerté sur l'oeuvre de victor hugo
j'avais à l'époque 5 6 ans c'était un
soir sous l'occupation dans un train
j'étais avec ma mère et les papiers de
ma mère n'était pas très trésor avec les
un moment donné un contrôleur donc s'en
est aperçu et nous a demandé de le
suivre dans le dans le dans le couloir
pour vos propos sûrement nous arrêter et
ma mère a eu très très peur et à ce
moment là elle a enlevé sa montre elle a
donné ça montre aux contrôleurs
le contrôleur nous a laissés retourner
dans le compartiment et en se rasseyant
elle a dit qu'elle thénardier voilà
j'avais 5 6 ans à l'époque et je lui dis
qu'est ce que c'est qu'un thénardier à
partir de là tout est parti et c'est
comme ça que ce soir là ma mère pour la
première fois à essayer de me raconter
comme on peut raconter un enfant 5 6 ans
les misérables pour la première fois
alors on va revenir en votre compagnie
sur sur ce film bien évidemment que je
vous propose de voir tout de suite en
images le film les misérables racontée
par pascal deschamps quel est l'acteur
qui rêvent pas tuer jean valjean comme
vos claude lelouch ou jean paul belmondo
a donc chausser les godasses du plus
célèbre bagne en deux poules est dans le
nom a changé le siècle aussi mais
l'injustice et les galères sont toujours
là alors comme le héros de victor hugo
celui des misérables du xxème siècle
traversera le siècle et ses poumons
le siècle avec ses deux guerres c'est
petit et ses grands ouverts ce que
j'aime beaucoup dans ce personnage c'est
qu'est il est un héros
disons malgré lui va faire des choses
sans avoir décidé de les faire c'est la
vie qui va l'entraîner et devant
l'obstacle qui va se comporter en héros
on s'en fout ça
trois heures d' aventure trois heures
d'émotion de mélo mais aussi d'humour
trois heures où s'entrecroisent les
destins car pour qu'il y ait des gens
valjean des causes est le gars franches
pour qu'il y ait des bons il faut aussi
des méchants des couples de thénardier
profiteurs mesquin et pathétique comme
gauche y rencontre des thénardier on en
rencontre toute sa vie je crois que tout
le monde ont rencontré il faut être prêt
à les affronter et à se méfier s'est
passé ce qui ressort lui à la fin de sa
vie et qu'il faut faire du bien aux
autres quoi je crois que c'est ça qui
est important
donner du bonheur aux autres c'est la
leçon apprise par ce jean valjean donner
du bonheur aux acteurs c'est aussi le
credo de lelouch ne puis un quart de
siècle un plaisir qu'ils vous invitent
plus que jamais à partager lui qui dit
avoir vécu ses plus grandes émotions
dans les salles obscures car les
misérables du 20e siècle
c'est aussi sa façon à lui de dire merci
aux frères lumière si victor hugo avait
vécu au 20e siècle
peut-être aurait-il fait du cinéma
claude lelouch on voit il ya
d'innombrables personnages dans votre
film est ce qu'ils sont tous des
référents tous pardon des références à
votre propre histoire
ils sont tous des références d'abord aux
misérables de victor hugo et ensuite à
mes observations personnelles vous savez
que j'ai toujours l'habitude de faire
des films à partir de choses plus ou
moins vécu dont j'ai été le témoin et
c'est vrai que j'ai réussi à enfin j'ai
réussi j'ai essayé de sueur impressionné
tous les personnages qui m'avait fasciné
dans ma vie et qui se retrouvent dans le
roman de victor hugo parce que ce qui
est formidable dans leur monde victor
hugo c'est que une fois pour toute c'est
l'histoire de l'humanité il ya toute
l'histoire de l'humanité et j'ai pensé g
j'ai eu envie de réactualiser cette
histoire parce que hélas hélas cette
histoire n'est toujours pas démodé l a
jamais été autant d'actualité c'est ce
qu'on a essayé de faire mais avec en
plus je crois énormément d'humour
énormément d'humour parce que c'est
peut-être ça la grande nouveauté du
xxème siècle c'est que les hommes et les
femmes commencent à rire de leur petit
musée puisqu'il voit qu'il ya pas
d'autres solutions et puis surtout j'ai
fait ce film parce qu'il y avait un jean
valjean extraordinaire qui est belmondo
et puis j'avais autour de moi des
acteurs extraordinaires et ça je veux le
dire je veux le crier j'avais un casting
de rêve je peux pas tous les citer il y
en a énormément mais je crois que c'est
ça la grande force du film c'est les
performances des comédiens qui sont tous
bouleversant émouvant et je les en
remercie publiquement
voilà je pense qu'ils seront satisfaits
michel boujenah vous vous jouez dans le
dans le film les misérables le rôle d'un
avocat juif qui est obligé de fuir puis
de se cacher vous avez vous aussi le
sentiment qu'on a dans notre vie des
périodes où nous sommes tantôt
thénardier tantôt jean valjean
ben on les oui je pense que quand le
mauvais côté ne nous prend pas sur le
bon on a tendance à des thénardier
et puis heureusement s'il ya des valeurs
auxquelles on croit
eh ben on redevient valjean mais quand
on voit le début du journal télévisé
avec les types on se dit il ya une
sacrée bande de thénardier en liberté en
sombre attendait jean valjean quand même
et évidemment des jean valjean mais on
parle en ce moment beaucoup plus des
nordiques des jean valjean
j'aimerais bien savoir qui est jean
valjean et qui est cause est il y en a
beaucoup
il y en a beaucoup mais c'est les
thénardier qui sont en haut de la fiche
en ce moment
donc c'est vrai que c'est vrai que on a
le sentiment comme ça qu'on peut tous
basculer d'un côté ou d'un autre et que
ça se joue sur une seconde de choix dans
des moments importants où on se
raccroche
instinctivement aux choses que l'on
croit aux valeurs auxquelles qu'on a
envie de défendre et le personnage que
je joue il est comme ça et il pourrait
devenir la thénardier
alors vous aussi on retrouve également
avec un immense plaisir annie girardot
dans ce film annie girardot vous vous et
une fidélité sans faille à claude
lelouch
ah oui c'est mon cinquième prime avec
lui avec eux je suis tranquille je veux
dire quand il m'appelle c'est que il va
se passer quelque chose quoi quoi je ne
sais pas on le saura au moment du
tournage et c 'est kervéguen oui et on
dit toujours que avec claude lelouch il
se passe quelque chose quand la scène a
été a été terminée c'est toujours
ensuite qu'il se passe quelque chose est
ce que c'est ce qui s'est passé pendant
le film via notamment des scènes
fantastiques
vous êtes presque à huis clos avec
philippe léotard qui joue le rôle d'un
agriculteur dont vous êtes la femme dans
le film
oui et puis j'ai aussi mon notre
prisonnier évidemment dans le cachot
dans notre nom de faire mon ami dans un
trop là pour faire croire que la guerre
n'est jamais fini ce n'est pas fini et
puis et cetera et cetera
et c'est ce que disait le loup justement
ces gens ils sont très brave cc
thénardier là et sont des bons fermiers
et oublie évidemment alors donne
l'occasion de ceux ci alors évidemment
ben ils vont ils vont tomber comme comme
tout le monde quoi
mais de tourner avec l'autre c'est
étonnant parce que je sais toujours que
s'ils m'appellent c'est qu'il ya besoin
de moi et que moi j'ai besoin de lui
aussi mais je voudrais savoir exactement
comment mais je sais que
j'attends le moment du tournage et bi et
puis j'y trouve pas ce que j'ai envie de
l'épaté à cette fois le jour j'ai pas
très plus j'emploie claude et ben bassat
c'est fini mais je crois que ce n'est
pas très ravie lhimer l'aude où je vous
avais été épaté par un idiot à la ola
cinq fois et puis j'ai été épatée aussi
par alexandra martinez par jean marais
je rêvais de tournai jean marais et
micheline presle darry cowl c'était un
rêve pour moi de tourner à darry cowl
philippe khorsand ticky holgado
clémentine célarié qui est une pure
merveille je vous dis je voudrais les
citer tous et puis et puis je voudrais
citer mon ami francis lai qui nous a
fait une musique de rêve avec
barbelivien avec michel legrand je
voudrais tous les sites et j'ai envie de
citer les gens j'ai envie de parler du
film j'ai envie de citer tous ces gens
là qui ont vraiment été fabuleux du
début à la fin
vous allez vous faire tout petit dans
une salle de cinéma comme on voit un
petit garçon regarder un film sur un
écran de fortune quand le film va sortir
mercredi ya intérêt pas même pas
mercredi demain soir et demain soir en
avant première à paris berlin soir à 23
heures aura lieu la première publique au
gaumont italie donc les gens peuvent
venir dès demain soir et tous dimanche
ou lundi et où mardi dans une salle à
paris au gaumont italie on va faire
toute une série d'avant-premières mais
public donc dès demain soir je vais tout
petit petit qui provient justement quand
on voit un film on le voit en projection
apprend le voit au doublage et c'est le
jour où on voit le film c'est le jour où
il est public
voilà merci ben le film n'est à ce
moment là merci beaucoup annie girardot
merci michel boujenah et claude lelouch
merci à francis les les misérables donc
en avant première demain soir je répète
et à partir de mercredi sur tous les
écrans merci beaucoup d'avoir été en
direct avec un dernier mot pour vous
dire que demain entre 12h et 15h notre
chaîne retransmettra le mariage de
l'infante d'espagne
vous voyez sur ces images la reine
sophie a inspecté en quelque sorte
l'église dans laquelle ne sera célébrée
ce mariage la cathédrale de séville tout
le gotha mondial s'est donnée rendez
vous demain pour le mariage
de la fille du roi juan carlos et de la
reine sophie voilà c'est la fin de ce
journal après la météo nathalie rihouet
le point route avec valérie maurice le
dernier journal ce sera vers une heure
du matin présenté par catherine ceylac
demain à 13 heures benoît duquesne et je
vous retrouverai à 20 heures je souhaite
une très bonne soirée merci